I reacted to South Park Medical scenes
last year and you liked it so much you
came out to my tour and begged for more
I need more South Park commuters or at
least one of you did huge thank you to
shipstation for sponsoring this video
okay Kenny I'll bet you a hundred
dollars you can't let a fart on fire
[Laughter]
[Music]
he didn't just light a fart on fire lard
a fart on Fire Light a fart on fire he
actually lit himself on fire
why is he bleeding profusely yeah you
have skin damage and some blood loss but
you're not just shooting out gushing out
blood
try to untangle straight in esophagus
untangle his trachea and esophagus the
trachea being your windpipe your
esophagus being your food pipe like why
are they Tangled
[Music]
this looks like my virtual simulator
this is why you go to medical school you
throw the intestines away
so you got to do Chaska brushes chest
no you don't gotta zap it you gotta
squeeze it he's putting in the microwave
who's making a potato is that George
Clooney Kenny
Kenny can you hear me how are you
feeling son
great son I have some bad news we
accidentally replaced your heart with a
baked potato you have about three
seconds to live so he wouldn't wake up
is what you're saying in all reality
burning yourself is quite dangerous
because it causes you to lose fluids
because skin prevents fluid loss and you
need to carefully manage not just fluids
but electrolyte balance in patients who
have severe burns
colleges Chef he's a doctor that
specializes in your [ __ ] children
we've moved away from using the term
Proctologist to now discussing that
specialty as colorectal surgery some
people confuse the GI Doctrine or
colorectal surgeon they both focus on
the GI tract colorectal surgeon is a
surgical field that mainly focuses on
the anus rectum and intestines where the
GI doctor focuses on the usually mostly
non-surgical approach of the entire GI
tract from the mouth to anus there are
both colorectal surgeons and GI doctors
who perform colonoscopies usually though
what happens is the GI doctor performs
the colonoscopy and if they find
something that needs removal they then
send them to a colorectal surgeon that's
usually what happens what seems to be
the problem we just want you to take a
look and tell us if you see anything
abnormal other than its monstrous size
well proctologists also don't look at
buttocks so they wouldn't tell you
anything about your glutes well the
prostate seems to be normal
no swelling of the hermodo plane
wait what's this
okay alien satellite dish not usually
found in rectums 2022 line Dr Mike
[Music]
you know that feeling when you take a
huge dump uh well doctor I've never
quite seen this before perhaps he just
needs some hemorrhoid cream
hemorrhoid cream is usually focused on
dealing with inflammation so there's
some kind of steroidal components of the
cream there's also pain relief component
sometimes like lidocaine or benzocaine
hello everyone my name is John Garner
and I'm a nutrition advisor from the
USDA there's been a lot of confusion
about gluten lately and there's also
been a lot of confusion because of your
ridiculous food pyramids that make no
sense people saying that gluten is the
cause of cancer gluten should be avoided
gluten can make your dick fly off but
let's set the record straight make your
dick fly off so what is gluten gluten is
the protein component found within wheat
gluten is the protein found in flour
when you take all the starch away not a
bio weapon just harmless flour protein
then eat it excuse me if it's not
dangerous then eat that pure
concentrated gluten okay yeah all right
crazy a robot
oh you see there's Dick's flying off we
did have a period in time where people
were deathly afraid of gluten there was
a good reason for some people to avoid
gluten those who have celiac disease
which is a true autoimmune disease that
when your intestines are exposed to
gluten your body starts to have an
autoimmune reaction where it starts
attacking the intestines so basically
your intestines in order to have more
surface area for better absorption have
these little projections called Villi
and these Villi actually are the ones
that made contact with gluten present
them to the body and then your body
starts attacking these projections
called Villi therefore you get blunting
of the villa and they get short which
can lead to malabsorption lack of
certain nutrients and vitamins diarrhea
bloating pain Etc and there are some
situations where you have non-celiac
wheat sensitivity where eating wheat can
actually give you an upset stomach but
it's not an autoimmune disease like
celiac disease that's why when you go to
a restaurant some people say like oh I
prefer to avoid gluten-based products is
one thing but if you're a person with
celiac disease you want to avoid having
Foods prepared in a facility where
glutinous is it there's hot dog buns in
that cupboard Sharon Hey Dad I need to
talk to you about this party we're
having oh my God the Wheat Thins The
Matrix gets too Randy wait wait I might
need those this stuff will make your
dick fly off Stan the thing that
surprised me the most because there was
a period of time where I uh when
gluten-free was soy sauce has gluten in
it what about ice cream I don't know
it's sometimes used as a thickening
agent heavy cream sugar chocolate syrup
no ice cream
what's going on
well that's just a beer oh Jesus beer is
we're gonna need you to come with us sir
don't touch me look I'm okay you want to
see my dick we just need you to be in
quarantine for a while until everyone
figures out what's going on how'd you
get exposed Bagels
gravy
beer I didn't know it had gluten there's
always something for me it was the soy
sauce
[Applause]
sir We've Got a Boy On The Hotline who
says he might know something
who is this my name is important what
matters is that the answer is in the
pyramid we built the Pyramid a long time
ago to illustrate how much people should
eat of the four basic food groups and it
was she was pyramid guidance ever it's
upside down
what
sir we've got a match nutrition is
stabilizing we've got a well-balanced
vaccine sir
get the president on the phone
tell them to have some steak with his
butter
please don't do that the saturated fat
is out of control let me quickly tell
you about chip station the leading
web-based order management and shipping
software it's designed to make retailers
lives Easier by processing fulfilling
and shipping e-commerce orders more
efficiently I know the hassle of running
an online business I've been shipping
out merch for the better part of a year
so I understand the value of having the
right tools before you get started
imagine if I started selling merch
before having solid management and
shipping infrastructures in place I'd be
buried in orders and unable to grow my
business thanks to shipstation you can
focus on growth from day one as they
eliminate the headaches that come with
printing labels handling orders across
multiple platforms like Amazon
Etsy eBay even your own website get the
same discounted shipping rates as
Fortune 500 companies whether you're
sending a stack or a truck full a
hundred thirty thousand companies have
grown their e-commerce business with
them and 98 of companies that use them
for one year become customers for life
ship more and grow more with shipstation
go to shipstation.com Dr Mike remember
doctor is spelled out and if you sign up
today you're going to get a 60-day free
trial start today and get set up before
the biggest shipping season of the year
that's two months free all right let's
get back to some South Park hello boys
your mommy has a bacterial infection
called C diff oh that's problematic
Clostridium difficile is the type of
bacteria that can live in the gut but
then once it multiplies and it becomes
to the Infectious level it creates foul
smelling heavy watery mucousy diarrhea
so much so that you could transfer it to
other people through contact we actually
in hospitals when a patient tests
positive for C diff put them on contact
precautions where in order to walk into
the room you have to glove up gown up
and then wash your hands with soap and
water before and after all of us have
trillions of microscopic Critters that
grow on and inside our bodies and some
of them actually help us with digestion
we can't use antibiotics because that
will kill all the good bacteria too well
that's not true we absolutely have
antibiotics that we can use in fact one
of the common antibiotics we use is one
called Vancomycin is a very potent
antibiotic that we usually use through
IV methods because it is not well
absorbed when you're taking it orally
but now imagine if you have an infection
in your intestines and you want the
medication to stay there then taking a
medicine that is not well absorbed
actually is beneficial hence why we use
Vancomycin in these types of infections
so what can you do for her we need to
take a healthy person's microbiome and
start to grow it inside your mother we
do this with a fecal transplant we'll
get a donor species mix it with water
and put it up your mom's anus we
actually do do fecal transplants that
actually has really good high rates of
clearance of the infection I recently
saw there were some medications being
tested where they actually freeze-dried
some of that poop into capsules and then
you take it and then it opens up in your
your intestines and it serves the same
purpose
yeah but it's in capsules because if you
don't if you don't take it by mouth the
only other way to do it is through a
colonoscopy as I call you all together
because I think you might be making a
mistake putting your children on Ritalin
but our kids have attention deficit
disorder Chef they can't pay attention
in school without it there's this doctor
in Northern California who is doing
really amazing things with kids who have
ADD I want you to watch this tape for
attention deficit hyperactivity disorder
Ritalin is a medication that is
prescribed it's similar in nature to
Adderall although it's a different
medication inside inaderol you have like
an amphetamine-based prescription
whereas in Ritalin it's methylphenidate
what's different is the time of onset so
in Ritalin the peak comes sooner than it
does on Adderall therefore it lasts for
a shorter period of time this treatment
is fast and effective and doesn't use
harmful drugs watch closely as I apply
treatment to the first child by the way
there are legitimate non-pharmacological
behavioral options for children and
adults who are diagnosed with ADHD
sit out and study
now I laugh at this because it's South
Park but in reality this is kind of
mean-spirited because patients who have
true ADHD it's not as simple as just sit
still their mind is literally racing and
it's not a discipline issue it's a
biological issue and at the same time I
will say there are parents and children
mostly parents that request medications
for their children when it's probably a
lack of discipline that is the issue
which one would I say is a greater
problem I think it's worse when you poke
fun at people who actually need the
medicine and would benefit from it but
it's more problematic to society when
you put children on medicine that they
don't need what do you think I can have
Dr Shea come to South Park for a small
fee that video had pretty colors it sure
did damn it have you all been taking
your children's written too yes well
adults have ADHD too and it's not
necessarily runs in families but there
is a potential genetic component there
special chaos cannot be stuffed oh yeah
Kitty use your ninja star
[Music]
oh ninja starts to the eye
don't pull it out seek help immediately
just stay still oh no
just why would you do this
dude you're gonna scramble his brain
you're not gonna scramble his brain
you're gonna cause him to bleed out you
guys can't
yes please we need a doctor but we can't
go to the hospital and you need a very
specific doctor because if you bring me
I ain't doing smack wait wait what about
the veterinarian Dr he's really old and
going blind so if we make Butters up to
look like a duck oh no
[Music]
maybe the Marlin glue we need more fur
over here this reminds me of those
mobster movies where uh they can't go to
see a doctor so they go to the local vet
to pull out the bullet
[Music]
what
kind of sick bastard would do this to a
dog poor little pup
can you help him doctor I'm afraid I
wouldn't know how unfortunately for this
little fella I'm a people Doctor best we
call the animal shelter right away like
I can't and react to this because
there's nothing I can say I ain't doing
smack
Randy why is again the stupid chart
looks like he's in a recession in the
stock market like what are we looking at
and what are the vitals and bar graphs
above his bed he got served worst I've
ever seen this dancing was so fast I
couldn't do anything his moves were so
original so inventive why does he need
nasal cannula oxygenation for that he
mostly got served here and here but the
worst serving was here in the pelvis
region the road to recovery will be a
long one what is the injury is it a
fracture do you know what happened to me
this morning Stan this morning I woke up
and felt a sharp pain in my ass I felt
down there and found this big sore lump
was it a pimple was it a hemorrhoid
which part of your ass are we talking
about I have a hemorrhoid and Cartman
has his own theme park that's not the
end of the world a lot of times
hemorrhoids happen from people spending
a lot of time on toilets a lot of time
it's from cell phone use people just
hang out for a long period of time
bearing down a lot when having bowel
movements usually as a result of
constipation that can happen so
increasing fiber is really smart what's
that it's my seat ring I have to sit on
it because of my hemorrhoid that heat
ring not only helps with hemorrhoids but
also coccydynia come on dude
loved it
hit my birds what the hell are you doing
oh crap oh my god get me off of here a
bleeding hemorrhoid that has thrombosed
bleeds very heavily
[Music]
it's not just cream a lot of times it
might need surgical Intervention when I
say surgical intervention it could be
something as simple as a banding
procedure where we literally put a put a
tight Band-Aid over the area and it
chokes it out of its blood supply it has
a result it ends up falling off I'm
sorry your son appears to be losing the
battle
what is he septic I'm afraid that the
Hemorrhoid has spread to his lungs what
what blood vessel that has extended
usually to the point where it can't
shrink back down if it got infected it's
now infected and expanded not something
that's contagious normally the body
would fight the infection but he's he's
just given up on life but then are you
saying there's nothing more I can do
little fellas just lost his will to live
you could just give him an antibiotic
and cheer him up but I will say mindset
is an important factor in whether or not
someone gets better and how fast they
get better those who have a positive
optimistic Outlook do tend to fare
better goes hand in hand with the
placebo studies and the sugar pill
people 30 of the time experience the
same effects as the ones who got the
real medication yeah that's a pretty bad
lice problem there good thing they
pulled you out of school well actually
lice people think lives in in dirty hair
but the reality is cleaner hair makes it
easier to transfer lice and also for the
lice to move around and get comfortable
a maximal killing power
these are cute lice what is that
you know you never think about things
like that
I feel bad for life now
my sympathy goes up for lice replace did
you know I performed surgery virtually
Surgeon Simulator and virtual reality
click here to check that out and don't
forget to visit chipstation.com Dr Mike
to begin your 60-day free trial as
always stay happy and healthy foreign